he is a six-time indycar series winner
our friend graham rahul how are you sir
i'm good rich how are you doing better
for talking to you
grant i'm doing i appreciate that how's
life
life is good man now i've no no
complaints
um you know gearing up for this weekend
we're
we're excited it's good to be back on
the show and chatting with you
yeah absolutely 40 venue capacity at the
motor speedway
for the 105th running of the indy 500 uh
on may 30th only on nbc so exciting
so exciting to be yep you go right 40
you know 40 percent but it's better than
indianapolis is still 140
000 people unreal um yeah
so it will be the largest spectator
event um
you know of uh well since covet
um you know every year the indianapolis
500 is the world's largest single day
spectator event with around 300 000.
so we got 40 this time and you know
we're we're excited because
it would be it is it it'd be like
playing the super bowl with no fans or
playing the national championship game
with no fans it's not the same
you know the fans make the energy they
make the atmosphere and
what it's all about so we're excited man
we're excited for the weekend
how does one um prepare for an indy 500
graham walk me through that by coming on
the rich
well i mean that's that's no no hold on
a second that's the way winners prepare
great exactly okay exactly no i
you know honestly it it takes so long
there's so much it goes into it i mean
going back
from a car perspective to give you a
sense like the the car i'm racing this
weekend
it's it's it's only rodeo of the whole
year you know we prepare this car and
massage on it all winter long to make
sure that um
you know every little body gap and seam
and everything is ready to go
and perfect you know for time we show up
at indianapolis so
there's really nothing you know that we
spend that sort of time doing and from a
driving perspective
i mean i've been doing it a while maybe
you know should have should have won one
of these or to uh
by now but uh you know you you kind of
get used to
the pressures the expectations the
nerves and how it all flows and what's
going to happen
so um you know we feel
we feel good about our chance i mean
last year we finished third but we we
feel
extremely good about our chances this
time around it's exciting i'm excited
for you graeme ray hall and plus this is
the first
if i'm not mistaken indy 500 you'll be
racing as a dad
right correct it is my first it is my
first as a dad so yes i'm
i'm super excited about that it's been
great
you know to have my wife courtney and
harlan our baby you know with us uh
during this month of may and all the
festivities and craziness that goes
along with it and
um you know so it's been it's been
tremendous to uh
it changes things i mean i know you and
i talked about kids before and just you
know the joy that it brings in life and
it's just there really is you don't you
don't get it everybody tells you you
don't get it so you have one
and now i've got one and i get it uh now
you get it huh
what do you what's the idea that you get
are you crying at commercials now graeme
is that what you're doing what are you
getting
no i haven't done i haven't had that
opportunity yet no
it's common graham what about but you're
not you're in the diaper changing
business of course right you're oh man
i'm good at that like it's like a pit
stop
myself how many seconds does it take
to make sure you get the flaps tucked in
nicely so that's like a tire chain you
got to make sure all the all the nests
are tight
that you're ready to go but no it's it's
been awesome and it's so cool
and uh you know even on a bad day at the
track uh
you know you come on back to the bus or
to to home here in indy and
and see her and you know life's good
again it just brings it
in so many ways it complicates life but
in so many ways too it simplifies it and
that's uh
you know the the joys of life at least
and it's been been great oh
that is the the conundrum of parenting
right there
the complications but also the immense
joys
in men's joys um is it true just you can
confirm this rumor or not that
your your daughter's nickname is bo you
have you nicknamed her beau
that's no no sorry sir that's not hold
on a minute how about
harbs harbs no
no no no no i mean i was watching all
the stuff before i came on and i just
i mean i you know you
you talk about like this you know lucky
you know overtime thing and stuff but i
think that was just back at the time
when
you know michigan was just still
overrated and you know it became it got
a little too close closer than it should
have
but i'm not going to name or nickname my
daughter anything to to do with that
that school um unfortunately that's cool
you know graham i appreciate your
dislike and disdain for michigan
i appreciate you no no here's i do
appreciate it immensely
i appreciate it more than when i got out
of herb street the other day when he
came on to promote the draft
or breer which is the com which is the
you know i mean it's so much better i i
hope michigan's better because
it's so much better for the rivalry it's
so much better for the big ten
like i i don't believe that for a heart
for a second
hold on a second i don't believe that i
didn't hear herbs interview but i will
agree with that
it would be better for a rivalry if
michigan actually could win once or
twice
no no no no no no no hold on a second
you don't want michigan to win ever
so i don't so why don't you basically
say it's better
it's better for us that michigan stinks
or does
it was like within if it was like within
a few touchdowns score every year maybe
it'd be better
you know for for for you know just for
the for the league
and actually just for the league's
relevance that you know michigan
can compete in a bowl game maybe or
something so when michigan
when michigan gets to a national
championship semifinal or
final that will happen um in the
lifetimes
of us graham and beautiful harlan
it's going to stop it's it's all
cyclical we all know it
i i i will i will you will be my first
guest
on the show to talk about how you're
rooting for michigan because it's you're
so concerned about the league
writ large in the conference writ large
i can't wait for that day
because that's going to happen no you'll
say that right when that happens
you'll say that right right i don't i
don't know
i don't know that i can i don't know if
i maybe i'll cheer for him to get there
but i think i don't
i don't think i want to see him win a
national championship inside that's the
quality no don't apologize graham
because you're being honest
you're being honest instead of this
whole business of like oh gosh it's be
so good for the conference because
you're so worried about the conference
because you're just because you're a big
ten man through and through you're not
you're an ohio state
the ohio state man through and through
and you don't want michigan to be that
good
you don't want to have a scare put in
you you don't want to go wow that was a
great
game you want to be like oh yeah i'll go
on rich's show and talk about
how we beat him by 40. that's what you
want there there is there is no doubt
that i uh that i do enjoy
uh i do enjoy the beatings uh
or the waving of the white flag last
year uh by michigan
oh jeez oh man graham
come on play the hits graham don't
don't go there you can't go there
you're you're because you are uh at at
your heart
your dna a competitor you're from a
family of competitors
come on you know michigan's not duck in
competition
you know it well you know it deep down
come on now who knows
who knows oh no he knows right now all i
know is
right now you know my we're not gonna
we're not ducking any competition and
we've got our
our eyes on uh on the weekend you know
and
we're excited for uh for what's to come
and
okay you know one of these days rich you
gotta come out and see this thing i
think i asked you but i don't think
you've ever been to an indy 500.
no i think you've you've done it all and
i know you've done everything else
no i appreciate that and i appreciate
you attempting to change the subject
because uh you know here's what i'm
excited about you know what i'm excited
about graham
i'm excited to see justin fields win
enough games to beat mike tomzak's
record for most wins in the nfl by an
ohio state quarterback
i hope you're right i'm hoping i'm
hoping fields can do what
dwayne haskins probably won't rj bear
you know jt barrett
never never had a shot to do yeah you
know what i mean i'm looking forward to
that i'll give you i'll give you that
edge you guys got one guy who uh
uh carry michigan football as a
quarterback a lot further than the ohio
state
that one guy again that one guy has
carried it further than anybody else
that's never had
one gun he has just one man all right
who
you you can't say his name either like
like the like michigan you can't say his
name
no you know what so he was another guy
brady isn't a tom brady
yes tom brady there's another guy that i
hated
right because he was a michigan man
right but then i came to find actually
that now i do nothing but cheer for him
because you know there's a
level that you just have to accept
pure greatness and accept that what
we're watching may never be seen again
in the way that a guy can just lead and
i was with scottie miller
uh actually at saint p he came to our
race in st pete and i asked him about
brady
and he was just talking about just just
first off like he might as well be the
coach
and then second off just his his
capabilities to be able to completely
lead the organization and even even here
in india i work out at a place up north
and a lot of nfl has come in a ton
and you know i was talking to one the
other day that uh
that plays down in uh new orleans uh
sheldon he's now gone to the
the jets but yep he's talking about
breeze and how breeze
breeze did that you know and breeze kind
of just carried the like
he didn't he thought that it was going
to be a real you know wake up for
not in a bad way for for peyton coach
pay but like just
how different it's going to be because
brees did so much
um to lead the team and yeah i mean you
know you gotta you gotta love guys like
that so
i've become a fan i must admit he's been
on fire today too i don't know if you've
been
able to check twitter uh after the
announcement of
it's gonna be him and phil mickelson
against um
against aaron rodgers and bryson
deshambo he's been on fire just trolling
out aaron rodgers all morning
well i haven't been paying attention to
it but i was just about to say i think
the two most hilarious people on social
media is tom
and phil nicholson and phil mickelson
phil mickelson has dominated social
media since he came on it he's a genius
well the two of them together are
defying age in terms of redefining age
in terms of sports i've got
graham ray hall here on the rich eisen
show tell me about your golf tournament
you got tomorrow you and courtney
the uh the graham and courtney rahul
foundation the annual golf tournament
that's going down
thursday prior to the indy 500 how can
anyone get involved to
help you raise some cash here graham
yeah so we do a big uh our biggest
fundraiser of every year
is our golf tournament uh our charity
our foundation
raises money for two uh two things one
is uh
what we call turn for troops that's uh
an initiative that we started with
united reynolds who's our primary
sponsor and
we we uh raise money to help veterans so
a lot of times it'd be a paralyzed
veteran who may need
and you know an exoskeleton to be able
to get up and walk which helps with
mobility and helps with um you know bone
density and muscle mass but also from a
morale standpoint you know to get up
we've helped develop
a ptsd treatment utilizing vr technology
so these are pretty advanced
technologies that we help provide
actually to va hospitals because most of
the time the va's don't have the funds
to be
buying 150 000 exoskeletons so we
provide it to them
uh so that many different veterans are
able to to utilize that
and then the other side is uh colorado
state university's one cure and we
through there we fund uh you know cancer
treatments uh with our furry friends
um with dogs and and they comparative
oncology
uh it's called and uh and actually we
our tournament is funding the very first
ever
ever clinical trial uh of a of a
treatment found in dogs for bone cancer
on children
uh we funded it at the university or at
denver children's hospital
and now it's moving on to atlanta's
children's hospital so we're extremely
excited by that
we'll have some auction items that will
be going up on my social media
there is a tom brady jersey peyton
manning jersey jason day
one of my buddies donated a a a drive
you know a tailor-made driver that he's
used and
signed so we have some great
opportunities and of course there's
racing stuff lots of racing memorabilia
but many others have helped us kind of
get uh get it up so we'll post that and
anybody can help i mean last year we
raised 331 000 that's awesome
you know our goal is to beat that and i
certainly uh i certainly think we
will at graham ray hall for that is that
the where
people should be able to follow that
stuff and and yeah and bid on these
auction items
yep twitter uh instagram facebook
and so it'll be it'll be up there
shortly we'll get a link posted and
everybody will be able to see it
fantastic you know it'll be live but
we're excited it's always a great day
and leading up to the indy 500 of course
most of our partners and sponsors and
everybody are involved they're all in
town it's a great way to kind of kick
off
uh this weekend and get everybody's
juices flowing excited for the weekend
that's uh awesome i'm thrilled to hear
that is dave coming to the race
letterman david you're coming letterman
will be here he uh we saw him two weeks
ago he came
um heard from him pretty frequently but
he will be back
uh he hasn't missed a 500 since i've
been around so i know
uh letterman will be here cheering us on
obviously last year our team finished
first and third
uh i unfortunately was the third not the
first right but this year we're gonna
try to turn that around and uh get dave
his third
you know third indy 500 win which is
pretty cool that's so cool
i mean that is you live a great life man
you've had a lot of uh
amazing things bestowed upon you and
amazing things that you've earned
and that is so cool that you know that
your dad and letterman together you know
are
put you in a race car for the indy 500
now you're doing it as a dad for the
first time yourself i'm happy for you
brother
i really am well like i said the invite
is always there
i'll take it dave would love to talk to
you oh my god you're don't just you're
the love of dave so
all right the invite's always there man
next year you gotta come
i would love to do that and in the
meantime um you know uh best to your
beautiful family and tell baby des uncle
rich says hi okay will you do that for
me yeah
okay okay okay thanks for the call
graham you take care of yourself all
right man you got it everybody check out
and let's raise money for graeme ray
hall at graeme ray hong good luck to him
in the indy 500. hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here